[MUSIC]
Conway's law was the idea that
what we create is a reflection of
our communication patterns.
Specifically, he was
talking about software,
but we can take a broader approach for
a second.
Silos are often simply
communication models.
It's the way in which
decision-making and
sort of ownership around a particular
set of problems gets discussed.
And so, one way that you can
start to break down the silo,
which is the first step,
like if it's animosity that's developed,
the first step is bringing those
people into your people, right?
What you want,
is you want to stop having the
perspective that the silo is the thing.
I often tell organizations to
stop shipping their org chart.
The very first thing that happens,
typically,
as we see that we're good at something,
is we want to double down on that value.
And so we do that by declaring,
this team does X..
And so, we start to align and
concentrate on a functional silo.
We put all the like things together.
Well, let me try to address
the history for a second, right?
I often ask development teams and
people doing a DEVap's transformation,
I ask them this simple question,
does a DBA need a database?
And then, people look at me
like I have nine heads, right?
But of course,
a DBA doesn't need a database.
DBAs were created, in some way,
by software engineers
who didn't want to deal with
the underlying complexity.
They needed a place to store their data,
but they didn't want to have to
deal with the runtime consequences
of bringing that database in.
And so, right off the bat in that model,
a silo gets created through
a particular kind of conversation.
As a software developer,
my value is solving problems with code.
Surely, there must be some other place,
some other functional group,
that can be accountable for
the build aspects of my software,
that can be responsible for
the infrastructure required to run it,
who can manage it in production.
So, we can talk about all
of these ways in which
I can maximize my personal
value as a software developer
by not being distracted by
the consequences of the choices I make.
And I think that DevOps takes
a totally different approach.
It says, sure,
there are a number of skills that
need to be applied in order to
ensure that the software and
technology that we build
is stable in production.
But it does not, the approach
that it takes is one in which,
is an inclusive one, that says we
are all sort of co-responsible.
So yeah, bring it, right,
if you're a database expert,
bring that expertise into the team.
But what I'm not going to do is I'm
not going to force you into a box in
which that's the only way that you can
express your creative intelligence,
with relation to this product that
we're putting out in the world.
As a matter of fact, I don't want that,
because you have had a broad history and
career, [LAUGH] you probably have,
there's probably a lot of awesome that
you can bring, in terms of understanding
that product, in terms of understanding
how it works in the world.
So, the approach that I would
take toward the animosity
would be first to heal it, right?
Like, the first thing you want to do is
you want to meet the people in the silo.
Hey [LAUGH], I'm right over here.
A lot of people have
that open spaces now.
My desk is right over there.
I would introduce yourself.
I would get to understand how and
why you were separated,
by understanding what value these people
bring, how they express that value.
And then I would look for
places where you can combine to improve
something in the infrastructure.
I bring that idea of sort of kaizen,
that's sort of gradual change over time,
or team improvement over time.
I would bring that idea
to your interactions.
So it's nice to get to know people,
it's great to make friends at work,
and I think that that's the basis.
Hi [LAUGH], who are you?
This is who I am.
What do you do?
This is what I do.
I think the very next step is, how
can we work together to make something
that's better than what we have today?